(host)
A primordial mother,
a divine female who births
the first generation of deities
in Mesopotamian mythology.
Tiamat is crucial
to life and death.
Tiamat makes up
the salty waters of creation.
The ocean is known for
its prolific capacity
to generate living organisms.
Life is born from the sea.
In the case of Tiamat,
so are monsters.
This ancient Mesopotamian
goddess produced
11 different frightening beasts,
from dragons to scorpion men,
but is Tiamat herself
really all that frightening?
Is the mother of
monsters even a monster?
[dramatic music]
I'm Dr. Emily Zarka,
and this is "Monstrum."
Much of Mesopotamian
mythology attributes
natural phenomena to
intelligent deities.
This becomes
particularly significant
in relation to rainfall, since
the region's early adoption
of an irrigation agricultural
system defined its success
and helped secure
the development
of numerous large-scale
permanent settlements.
Due to soil conditions, land
could easily become flooded
and salinized, making
cultivation challenging
and presumably at
the whim of the gods.
So it makes sense that
one of their central myths
would involve two
primordial bodies of water,
Apsu, source of all
fresh water, and Tiamat,
the source of all saltwater.
Tiamat's written history begins
around the second half of
the second millennium BCE
in the Enuma Elis,
now commonly known
as the Babylonian Epic
of Creation.
These cuneiform tablets
are the backbone
of Mesopotamian mythology.
Her appearance in this
text is ambiguous.
It reveals she is female,
but little else is known.
Although she is at
least somewhat humanoid,
it also indicates that
she is made of water.
This story gets a bit confusing
so I have this family
tree to help us out.
The language in
the text suggests
that the primordial
deities' mingling
involved biological
reproduction with Apsu
as begetter and father
of all and Tiamat
as the mother who births
all from her womb.
All of the original gods in
the Mesopotamian pantheon
are produced by these two.
As their progeny
in turn procreate,
each god becomes more
powerful than the next.
Ansar and Kisar's son Anu begot
Ea, also know as Nudimmud.
Ea was the champion
among his fathers,
god of wisdom, magic, and water.
Known for his
trickery and mischief,
he and the other Gods amused
themselves by making a racket
within Tiamat's belly,
where they lived.
One day, Ea overhears Apsu,
who we might consider
his great-grandfather,
complaining to Tiamat
about their children and
suggesting that they be killed.
Horrified and angered,
Tiamat refuses,
suggesting they take more
lenient disciplinary action,
which Apsu ignores.
Ea slaughters Apsu
and uses his body
to create a new dwelling
place which is named Apsu,
which is morbid AF.
All of this is still in
Tiamat's womb, by the way.
Patricide complete,
Ea has his own son Marduk,
the strongest yet of the gods.
Marduk is gifted with the
power of the four winds
and uses them to stir up
a flood wave in Tiamat's womb,
which exacerbates
all the other gods.
In a colossal act of
retaliation, either motivated
by revenge or insult
depending on interpretation,
Tiamat births 11
monsters into the world.
Girl made an army of kids,
ones with sharp teeth
and poison for blood,
giant serpents, dragons,
and raging dragons;
apparently there
is a distinction,
hairy hero men, lion men,
weather demons, snakes,
scorpion men,
fish men, bull men,
and the fantastically
ambiguous aggressive demons.
A bit panicked by
this influx of creations,
the other gods grant
Marduk the power
to create and destroy.
Ea further equips
his son with a scepter,
throne, staff,
and other weaponry.
Marduk makes a bow,
calls up some winds
and thunderbolts,
and readies for battle.
Marduk provokes Tiamat with
insults and she launches
into a hasty attack,
leaving herself vulnerable.
She is captured in a net
and overwhelmed by the winds
before Marduk's arrow pierces
her stomach, tearing her open.
He manages to subdue
her monstrous children
before returning to
Tiamat, crushing her skull
with a mace and slitting
her arteries open.
Marduk uses one half of her
dead body to form the heavens
and the other to
craft the earth.
From her eyes,
he creates the Euphrates
and Tigris Rivers, from her
breasts he makes mountains.
What is left of her
becomes the oceans.
He traps Tiamat's monstrous
offspring at his feet
and forms images of them
to place at the entrance
of the dwelling Apsu to remind
the world of their existence.
The Tiamat story can be
better understood by looking
at earlier, seemingly
disparate mythologies
that all blended
together to create
our monster mother's story.
Remember how Tiamat
birthed 11 monsters
to avenge her partner's death?
Well, that number pops up in
other, older Mesopotamian lore
like the Tale of Ninurta,
an ancient Sumerian warrior god
associated with agriculture
who slew 11 enemies
before designing the world.
And two Sumerian texts from
the late third millennium BCE
contain a list of monster
kin eerily similar
to those attributed to Tiamat.
And how many were there? 11.
Then there are monstrous
deities associated
with the tumultuous sea,
such as the Canaanite Yam.
Gendered masculine,
he is described
as both a serpent
and a dragon with seven heads,
depending on the source,
able to wield chaotic power.
Like Tiamat, Yam was defeated
by a heroic young god, Baal.
Tiamat herself appears
by name in an evocation
as patron of a fierce
warrior in a text
from Central Mesopotamia
around 2350 BCE.
Still nothing in the Canaanite
or Sumerian narratives
suggest Tiamat would be
a monster, just a powerful god.
Her great power is
admired and feared
but with respectful reverence
more than outright horror,
a potentially monstrous god
rather than strictly a monster.
But what would make
something a monster
by Sumerian or
Akkadian standards?
Well, there was no singular word
to categorize
fearsome creatures,
but their monstrosity
was marked
in images and texts
by a combination
of predatory animal features
like teeth, wings, and claws,
visual traits that would
be grafted onto Tiamat
in the Middle Bronze Age
and first millennium.
Marduk was once only
a local god said
to preside over the
city of Babylon.
His mythical status grew along
with the rise of Hammurabi,
the sixth king of Babylon.
To help solidify his control
over the people of the dynasty
and eventual rule over almost
all the peoples of Mesopotamia
the king used
the Code of Hammurabi,
a legal text
which basically boils down
to the laws of retribution.
Marduk's defeat of Tiamat came
to represent the installment
of the real-life Babylonian
king onto the throne
as the victor over
so-called chaos.
Marduk, or Bel as
he came to be known
as the new national
god, provided
a mythological representation
of good over evil,
law over lawlessness,
a fitting metaphor
for King Hammurabi's
right to rule.
The myth of Tiamat and
Marduk's great battle
received a ritual
portrayal every year
at a spring agricultural
festival called Akitu.
In the Neo-Babylonian period,
this would become a
New Year celebration
that lasted into the
Hellenistic period.
After that, Tiamat's story
was largely lost to time.
That was until the 19th century
when the Enuma Elis was first
translated into English,
giving Tiamat new prominence
in popular culture.
Today's modern
construction of Tiamat
is largely due to
Canadian author
and clergyman George A. Barton,
whose 1893 article
dubbed "Tiamat"
compares her to the
biblical serpent Leviathan
and the great red dragon
of Revelations.
Most damnably, he describes
her as a female dragon,
queen of a hideous host who
are hostile to the gods.
He goes as far as to say
that her apocalyptic imagery
indicates the popular
personification
of hideousness,
arrogance, and evil.
Even outside of this odd grab
bag of religious beliefs,
dude clearly has it out
for the primordial goddess.
Since then, Tiamat was commonly
painted as demonic chaos
as other publications adopted
a negative view of her.
She became, even
in her best light,
the bad mother in the story.
When Tiamat is adapted
for popular culture today,
she retains the
evil dragon status.
In "Dungeons and Dragons,"
Tiamat is not a mother
but a daughter,
the offspring
of the dragon creator god Io.
As a five-headed dragon,
she is said to be
in constant battle with
her brother, Bahamut.
"Final Fantasy"
also incorporates
the multi-headed dragon version
into their universe as well,
making Tiamat one of
the top-level bosses.
Although, as the
franchise continued,
she loses more and more heads.
If we look back at
Tiamat's 11 monsters,
it's possible to
identify precursors
to mermaids or sirens,
the Minotaur, Bigfoot,
or even whatever this is.
All the members of
Tiamat's monstrous brood
are meant to be frightening
because of their animalistic
qualities or inherent malice.
Unlike her other
godly offspring,
her monstrous children
were formed independently,
adding another threatening,
mysterious layer
to their existence.
Tiamat is both
nurturer and destroyer,
mother and monster,
as she chooses.
After all, Tiamat and every
god and monster she birthed
offers a fitting
Oedipal metaphor,
fear that our creations could
someday not only overshadow us
but literally destroy us.
I think I said Ham.
[laughs] Let's go back.
Do you think that 11 from
"Stranger Things" is 11
because of this whole, like...
It would be cool, right?
Eleven monsters.
That's my new theory.